allora siccome so che è più hills è un
gioco che me lo chiede anche mia nonna
di fare ho optato per non farlo più no
scherzo e che happy wheels ha dei
problemi innanzitutto il gioco perché fa
schifo no ormai livelli sono tutti
uguali si paga quindi ingiocabile per ho
trovato questa roba qua che mai fatta
molto bene ci sembra molto carino quindi
giochiamole proviamo way skilift goes
wrong e molto incollo tirelli e sono
contentissimo di giocarlo soprattutto mi
hanno scoperto che il rider che mi deve
portare i panini si chiama oro dell
stephen quindi nell'attesa che rode le
stime non mi porti panini giochiamo io
ordino dei panini si sono dei problemi
dell'america campagna non so bene penso
che ci sarà un semi tutorial che i
disabili teremo chissenefrega del
tutorial allora noi possiamo scegliere
di fare una funzione sta roba qua ai
tipo tutorial ha quindi io devo creare
semplicemente un passaggio che ero sono
riuscito a creare a quanto pare bene sta
finendo volto o peggio di quanto
pensassi questa faccenda
devo riuscire a tenere i passeggeri vivi
per per vincere livello che è molto
chiaro ha poi aggiungere degli oggetti a
per poi aggiungere gli oggetti per
agganciarci delle ruote che fanno andare
sulla funivia carino molto carino vabbè
mi sembra molto molto easy e poi vanno a
sciare si ammazzano probabilmente ok
nexta dentro iamm sono capito sono una
persona capita possono fare il giro
anche aspetto a vedere come funziona
aspetta da te la posso fare anch'io
orco demonio quindi posso fare anche i
livelli carino però mi schianto a
prescindere quindi oltre a costruire
posso anche muovere i personaggi
ok beh mi sembra un gioco fatto
benissimo come che non l'ho scoperto
prima a posto va a posto
porca che è facciata incredibile quindi
io devo costruire le cose per poter
andare avanti quindi mi devo questi
sostegni le robe del genere sembra molto
carino come gioco sembra fatto veramente
bene va bene andiamo avanti ho capito
devo costruire dello sopravvive
molto easy ho finalmente possiamo fare
le cose fatte bene dobbiamo raggiungere
quindi quel punto di pesos ho capito è
difficilissimo però ok alla piacevole
fondamenta che sono queste che le
metterei direttamente nelle fondamenta
un po strane fortunatamente io non
faccio l'ingegnere mi limito a fare lo
youtube e molto bene la costruzione
giusta dovrebbe essere questa secondo me
esporci un po a sinistra sta roba però
proviamoci non si sa mai mettere la roba
qua
vediamo se ci arriva allora passa da
quassù bene provaci kovacic tensione
attenzione attenzione tensione
l'ingegnere signori l'ingegner veramente
ha funzionato sta roba
ok non mi è morto è stato un caso non è
che morivano tutti vogliono tutti va beh
facciamo un altro l'altro sostegno devo
fare però se usiamo la stessa roba da
facciamo così posso mettere delle altre
fondamenta o un limite di 3.000 dollari
ne ho usati 1500 e piissimo sto gioco
siamo così facciamo un altro un altro
più grosso quindi così così
molto bene in teoria così dovrebbe in
teoria non ne sono completamente sicuro
ma vabbè mi servirebbe mi servirebbe
un'altra fonda mano attacchiamo la
all'albero bene l'albero fa da perno
ottimo questo lo togliamo che poteva
vedere se così funziona in teoria
dovrebbe funzionare
ok c'è qualcosa che è andato leggermente
storto però chi se ne frega e non
funziona lo stesso c'è più o meno perché
c'è l'albero lì vabbè maledetto albero
il natale ci rovina la vita però c'è
perché ci sono le fondamenta che sono
fatte un po a pene però va bene fa
niente rifacciamola para fondamento
stalli mi servirebbe un coso che tiene
le fondamenta di questo qua si sorregge
qua teoria dopo aver fatto editoriale
così che se proviamo
no c'è questa roba qua che non ha
sostegno perché ho libia ma dovrebbe
funziona non vedo perché dovrebbe cadere
è impossibile vai
ci ho messo una vita dovrebbe funzionare
poi non è detto però va bene
sì dai
minchia sei anni per fare sta roba
non ho preso la medaglia ma chi se ne
frega va bene a fanno il giro
addirittura wow efficace
bene gli avanti cosa ste cose qua champ
ha poi saltare solo provare a vedere
come funziona perché non so come acqua
questi invece devo mandare io va bene
vediamo come il jump bene non è come
pensavo allora è semplicemente una roba
che mi dà lo slancio rivedere cioè non
l'ho mai però devo provarlo prima perché
non l'ho mai provato vediamo porca vacca
un fenomeno rifacciamolo non avere avere
così sono arrivato al traguardo è un po
strano però devi mettere il supporto
vete supportare chi seguite mettete mi
piace la vita
il supporto è tutto in questo suo gioco
fighissimo poi nell'altro lo skilift
figate in gioco bellissimo all'acqua mi
ha già messo le basi quindi ha posto
però innanzitutto vediamo se riesco a
fare la base decente mi voglio scusare
il politecnico di tutte le cittadine del
mondo
se faccio ste cagate studiato fisica del
formaggio e allora questo in teoria
dovrebbe essere dice dovrebbe reggere se
gesù vuole che vediamo come funziona la
faccenda
poi voglio provare a fare questa cosa
per vedere che succede se regge la
faccio so prevedere che succede proviamo
non regge una se però che serviranno dei
supporti in più mi dicono vabbè annuncio
non ai supporti in più ok lo devo
sfruttare tutte le fondamenta che ciò
porco demonio perché non posso mettere
fondamentali facciamo mamma ci sono
anche lì a destra ne ho viste le live ed
è un servizio se regge stavolta a
reggerlo non so come per ora non ho idea
di come sia possibile infatti ho
centrato il cilindro però vale qualcosa
forse se costruisco anche qua il lavoro
il carico di lavoro si sposta su tutti e
due i fronti porco demonio sono addosso
prandi limiti di costi che palle dubito
si esibì in chiato tutto mas credo
funzioni mammamia rega allora queste
stabilizza tissima
se riuscissi incredibile incredibile
incredibile incredibile
non so come ho fatto sincero e ga non so
come ho fatto giuro try again
voglio provare a vedere una cosa adesso
che ho fatto sta roba se io faccio così
cosa succede
no per curiosità a farci ma come fa il
giro il tizio si scassa tutto
soprattutto vabbè andiamo se stavolta
regge eccolo sono uscita che arriverà
alla fine come va bene c'è una funivia
che è un po strana però funzionali
protette funzioni sono soddisfattissimo
della mia operazione guarda league
pam vabbè chi soltanto l'ho passato
livello l'importante è questa gente
morta
ok next questo è proprio minimal sono
arrivato al limite ho risparmiato 5 euro
posso comprarmi un panino oro delle
stime ho creato la sua funzione ok
proviamo così non son sicuro cioè storta
come la morte a parte che deve tirare la
gente se l'aveva non ti sai tenere non
ha dovute dovevo tenermi io coi comandi
ok quindi sono io che devo tenermi come
faccio tieniti fi forza con le mani
forza con le mani con le mani base scemo
per 6 dollari cribbio parte nuovo
scontro attimo un po storto ma teoria in
teoria c'è il poggiapiedi cioè il
poggiapiedi molto bene e la prova di
deficiente da già facevo anch'io a
passare alla voltura molto bene molto
bene sono soddisfatto di questa mia sono
bravissimo
sono molto soddisfatto ragazzi grazie
mille vedi ragazzi dire che fosse
concluso che sono soddisfatto ho passato
un po di livelli viene un pensavo mai di
passare ai ragazzi se vi sia piaciuto
taggato un amico che fa fondamenti senza
vestiti iscrivetevi e noi ci vediamo a
un prossimo video beh ragazzi
[Musica]